Aston Martin conjures up images of James
Bond and the many supercars that Q
outfitted with high-tech gadgetry images
that may well have been the inspiration
for the Aston lagonda in the 1970s and
80s
in 1976 one of the most spectacular cars
ever developed in the British Isles made
its debut and touched off a heated
debate some said it was plain ugly
others thought it had a certain
fascination among them a businessman
from Hong Kong but he wanted the car as
a station wagon Aston Martin never
intended to build a station wagon
version so in the late 1990s Swiss
company Bruce engineering got permission
to convert a sedan into the one and only
Aston Martin shooting-brake ever built
the well-to-do buyer already had a sedan
for special occasions but he wanted his
luxury and to take his dogs with him to
the Astin's 5.3 litre 309 horsepower
engine purrs along smoothly but
powerfully
and the James Bond spirit the onboard
computer keeps the driver informed by
voice
oil overheating water
overheating low fuel brake Aston Martin
was showing up its technical prowess in
the lagonda but nowadays unless the cars
have been overhauled a whole lot can go
wrong the models circuit boards and
contacts were prone to corrosion
wherever they could the swiss converted
the shooting brakes digital instruments
to analog so when the driver pushes a
button he can see and feel the result
only one Aston Martin Lagonda shooting
brake was ever built it's possibly the
sexiest station wagon and existence